bon
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur le plateau d' europe hebdo elle fait
payer public sénat pour cette nouvelle
édition nous sommes installés au coeur
du parlement européen à strasbourg
al'approche défaite on a choisi de
s'intéresser aux jouets ils sont testés
leur conformité et leur sécurité de
vérifier avant d'être mis sur le marché
reportage au port du havre avec les
douaniers qui réceptionne beaucoup de
marchandises venues notamment de chine
dont des jouets qui ne sont pas aux
normes
on en parlera dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission est d'abord l'actualité
la diplomatie européenne s'activent pour
tenter de régler la crise du crédit yens
pour parler d'une seule voix au proche
orient
mais au fait la voix de l'europe est
elle entendue c'est la question de la
semaine on se retrouve juste après avec
un invité pour en parler
elle est italienne lui polonais federica
mot guérini donald tusk
le nouveau tandem à la tête de l'europe
elle a été ministre des affaires
étrangères de matteo renzi lui ancien
premier ministre conservateur
elle dirige la diplomatie du continent
il préside le conseil de l'union
européenne désignée il ya quatre mois le
duo a été beaucoup moqué la première
pour son manque d'expérience
le second pour son niveau d'anglais trop
faible peu connu face à ces chiffres au
nez selon leurs détracteurs
et pourtant les dossiers à haut risque
se succèdent pour celle qui a remplacé
la britannique catherine ashton
son implication dans la crise
ukrainienne lui vaut les félicitations
de ses partenaires sous son égide
l'union a sanctionné la russie accusée
de soutenir les rebelles dans l'est du
pays engagés aussi au proche orient pour
son premier voyage officiel
elle s'est rendue en israël et dans les
territoires où elle a plaidé pour la
reconnaissance d'un état palestinien
des missions sensibles pour lui aussi la
réforme de l'union européenne alors que
londres menace de quitter la maison
commune si l'europe ne change pas ses
règles
le dossier énergétique du véritable
casse tête pour les européens très
dépendante du gaz russe
le nouveau président du conseil plaide
pour une union européenne de l'énergie
simple déclaration d'intention ou
premier acte politique d'une diplomatie
qui reste à inventer
l'italienne guérini et le polonais tos
ont-ils vraiment les moyens de faire
entendre la voix de l'europe sur un
continent qui préfèrent les petits pas
aux changements radicaux
notre invité cette semaine renaud
muselier bonjour bonjour réputé européen
élu en mai dernier vous êtes membre de
la commission des transports et du
tourisme et ancien secrétaire d'état aux
affaires étrangères
vous êtes aussi vice-président ici au
parlement européen de la délégation à
l'assemblée parlementaire
a cp afrique caraïbes pacifique d'un mot
j'étais un ancien président de l'uci
monde arabe le bassin méditerranéen est
essentiel le continent africain est
essentielle l'émigration vers l'europe
du nord sont à suivre de très près et
donc je pense le développement passe par
le développement africain je pense que
dans ce développement
l'union européenne a un rôle très
important on va en parler mais d'abord
peut-être un petit bilan de l'action
diplomatique de l'europe
est ce que pour vous le nouveau tandem à
la tête de l'union européenne dont on a
parlé federica mot guérini et donald
tusk est ce que ils font mieux que les
leurs prédécesseurs
ce qui est clair en tout cas ce qui est
clair en tout cas c'est que l'élection
de monsieur john kerr a recadré les
commissaires ses commissaires donc ceux
qui s'occupent de la diplomatie ont en
charge sur une ligne très fixe la
position de l'europe dans les
difficultés que l'on peut rencontrer
ils ont abordé avec beaucoup de succès
je pense la crise ukrainienne et les
européens se sont retrouvés non sans une
certaine difficulté par rapport au haut
conseil de l'europe s'est enfin aux
chefs d'état
le parlement européen la commission l'a
donc l'europe s'est exprimé de façon
claire cohérente et unis donc je crois
que c'est d'être en tout cas sur cette
opération à très efficace donc c'est un
bon début parce que c'était une crise
intense
d'abord parce que c'est une crise
humaine
maga entre le bloc de l'est et l'ouest
il ya des restes de l'ancien empire
soviétique avec des conséquences
importantes et des sanctions qui ont été
amenés aujourd'hui contre la russie se
doivent être entretenues mais on voit
aussi ça a des conséquences pour le
pétrole et les crises ou qu'il ait des
sanctions occidentales la russie de
recadrer son discours il faut penser que
c'est une bonne chose de sanctionner la
russie qui est quand même vous le dit un
partenaire essentiel pour le pense que
c'est un partenaire essentiel mais c'est
pas parce que c'est un partenaire
essentiel que ne faut pas tolérer ce
qu'ils essayent de faire taire des
membres d'un pays vous pensez que c'est
efficace effectivement on voit que le
rouble est en train de s'effondrer
vous pensez que c'est aussi la
conséquence aux affaires européennes oui
je pense que c'est un mélange de
l'occident etc etc pétrole c'est un
mélange des deux avec la volonté de
monsieur poutine de ne pas composer je
pense pour autant que l'on ne doit en
aucun cas à frémir trop la russie qui
est un partenaire essentiel pour la
suite et aussi notamment un partenaire
parce qu'on est dépendant du gaz
resteront dépendants l'un gaz russe on
est dépendant si sur le plan des pour
massy puisque c'était le sens du sujet
par rapport aux influences sur les
iraniens sur la syrie et que compte tenu
de notre environnement compliqué que ce
soit sur le nord de l'europe à leur
frontière avec la russie où le sud de
l'europe à nos frontières avec la syrie
la turquie israël on se rend bien compte
qu'on a aussi besoin la dent
dans une vaste discussion avec les
russes et ne pas aller trop peu trop les
éloigner parler d'israël en ce moment
les relations entre l'union européenne
certains pays l'union avec israël ne
sont ne sont pas forcément au beau fixe
parce qu'il ya un mouvement de
reconnaissance d'un état palestinien de
volonté de reconnaître l'état
palestinien dans beaucoup de pays
quand j'étais enfant j'ai enchaîné en
disant il faut que alors on connaître un
pays mais je pense que en ce moment la
manière dont c'est fait est-ce que les
chances de défaut non mes erreurs de le
faire comme ça sert que aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment pas le débat c'est pas le
débat et est ce que c'est le moment
c'est ni débat ni le moment
je pense que c'est une grosse erreur
mais je pense que c'est une grosse heure
parce qu'aujourd'hui on à israël qui est
un pays vraiment démocratique qui se
retrouve à un carrefour de tension
occidentale des tensions religieuses de
tension territoriales qui sont une
extrême violence
on voit qu'il ya danger sur le liban
danger sur la syrie danger sur la
jordanie un danger important sur
l'egypte et que c'est une fois en aucun
cas affaiblir israël
pour autant il faut bien être clair sur
la nécessité d'avancer sur deux états
mais quand on dit qu'on veut deux états
mais pas comme ça quel territoire
sur quel périmètre avec quel mode de
gouvernance avec eux peut-on reconnaître
un pays sans que pour autant les
palestiniens reconnaissent l'état
d'israël il ya quand même un certain
nombre de préalables qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui comme la ccc vote qui ont
ouvert dans plusieurs pays pour
reconnaître un état palestinien sont 1,6
soit politique c'est la politique une
faute politique c'est une faute
politique une fois de politique
affaiblir israël donné
un message à la palestine qui ne
reconnaît pas et israël l'état d'israël
et qui ne reconnaît en aucun cas tous
les massacres auraient lieu dans les
pays voisins sous un prétexte religieux
qui met en danger
l'islam est une faute politique mais
c'est aussi là pour la france voilà pour
la france mais alors ce qui est très
surprenant france c'est que normalement
c'est pas au parlement de dicter la
politique européenne de la politique
étrangère de la france
c'est au président de la république et
au parlement d'être unanime derrière lui
il est très surprenant de ne pas avoir
entendu le président de la république
s'est exprimé sur la position des états
israël ni le nie d'ailleurs le ministre
affaires étrangères monsieur fabius qui
lui n'a pas participé au débat
c'est quand même pas rien excusez moi du
peu que j'en aurai publique les mises et
étrangère de la france ne s'exprime pas
et ne participe pas au départ assez
nationale c'est une faute de rayonnement
de notre pays majeurs dit que c'est une
faute politique
alors vous parlez du président de la
république il a tenu cette semaine un
discours d'inauguration du musée de
l'immigration
c'est un autre dossier urgent pour
l'europe l'immigration je vous propose
d'écouter ce que dit françois hollande
notamment sur les accords de schengen
écouter
faire éclater schengen faire disparaître
schengen mais ça serait reculées ça
serait aboutir à rétablir des frontières
pays par pays
alors la france sera à l'initiative dans
les mois qui viennent non pas pour
défaire schengen mais pour mieux assurer
la sécurité à l'intérieur et le contrôle
à l'extérieur et pour mieux répartir les
charges qui pèsent sur les états membres
alors ces accords de schengen qui
autorise donc la libre circulation au
sein de l'espace commun ce qu'il faut
les revoir pour vous c'est sûr alors je
pense que c'est une réponse par rapport
à aux fonds national qui dit qu'il faut
sortir de schengen
je dirais simplement nos concitoyens que
ce qui se passe à lampedusa ils vont
l'avoir vintimille et si si c'est ça la
démarche c'est une encore une énorme
erreur politique de ceux qui n'aiment
pas leur pays et menton pour la france
en fait c'est ça au lieu de la voir aux
frontières de l'europe
on va le savoir devant notre porte ce
qui est quand même un peu plus compliqué
mais aussi il faut ne pas être bi des
bisounours quoi schengen
il faut pas sachant guen 2 voit bien que
dans l'ensemble de leurs séries et
européens
par exemple quand il dit il faut des
moyens supplémentaires web et qui les
donnent sur frontex ariane rats sont
frontex qui fait justement la
surveillance à nos frontières et qui
donne des moyens ne laissons pas les
européens seuls avec des moyens limités
ou les italiens seul sans leur donner
les moyens supplémentaires oui allons
jusqu'au bout de son raisonnement
donnant des moyens frontex pour protéger
nos frontières européennes allons aider
ceux qui sont aux frontières de l'europe
et s'ils sont défaillants faisons
derrière les pistes schengen doll est
indispensable on voit bien que il faut
distinguer deux savez vous pétez quoi
dedans qu'est ce que vous demandez
concrètement ses remords schengen et
améliorer schengen c'est à schengen est
une très bonne avancée mais schengen à
des carences et donc de schengen 2
pourrait s'articuler de la façon
suivante meilleur contrôle à l'intérieur
de ceux qui sont dans
la libre circulation c'est pour les
européens après les étrangers par
exemple harmonisation des autorisations
et différents pays quand vous
régularisez en italie en angleterre en
france un certain d'être angers parce
que il ya une pression migratoire très
importante quand ils régularisent
quelles sont les conséquences pour les
pays voisins attention ça ça doit être
traitée meliet et c'est une des
politiques de monsieur juncker
il ya eu peur l'immigration fait peur en
ce moment là ça fait les partis
d'extrême droite jouent sur cette peur
capitalise sur 7
je donne un exemple très concret la cour
européenne de justice a dit que les
cotisations sociales dans le cadre du
tourisme social
les pays membres de l'union européenne
n'avaient pas les payer donc ça revient
non pas à l'europe de faciliter la tâche
c'est l'europe qui est un pays
responsable si vous ne vais pas accepter
le tourisme social chez vous c'est une
législation française est donc enfin
vous avez compris sysmans de la
législation vous dites que ces trois là
je suis pour du nom ça lance en fait
j'étais moi ceux qui sont en situation
irrégulière qui souffre chez eux qui
sont malheureux chez eux et qu'ils
viennent chez nous c'est normal qu'ils
viennent chez nous que sa tante se faire
massacrer chez eux ce qu'on passe de 50
minutes dans notre propre pays à 250 me
on peut pas c'est comme si on parlait
avec certains pays tiers notamment la
libye parce que depuis elles sont je
pense qu'il faudrait africaine dans sa
globalité
parce que le vent et les plaignants à
lily allen ne croyait pas que la ville
ne soit pas sous la pression des peuples
du sud qui monte parce qu'on a vraiment
les moyens que les européens ont les
moyens de se faire entendre
bien sûr que je serai qu'est l'amérique
vous avez des politiques internes à
l'europe qui donne une liberté autonomie
au payement de ses pays membres se
doivent d'appliquer du bon sens et qui
sont à mon sens de traitement social
mais pas d'attractions d'attractivité
pour des gens qui parlent pas votre
langue qui n'ont jamais cotisé qui se
retrouve avec une le quotidien avait
l'air est sale et rémy et toute la prise
en charge possible ça c'est pas
acceptable pour les peuples européens
c'est impossible de faire ça pour autant
il faut aussi traiter un problème à
l'extérieur et à l'intérieur les et des
lapins le dialogue avec les pays tiers à
distance a d'ailleurs chez la commission
développement et parce que je sais très
bien que le bassin méditerranéen est un
lieu de passage énorme et on ne peut pas
le pape crochet la semaine dernière qui
est venu s'exprimer devant le parlement
qui a bien
expliqué que nous avions nous les
parlementaires nous les représentants de
ces 500 millions d'habitants un rôle
très important par rapport à ce
continent et pour yann delabrière
pour autant c'est pas un lieu de passage
et une autoroute de passage mais compris
merci beaucoup
renaud muselier d'avoir été notre invité
place maintenant aux reportages d'europe
et d'eau les jouets de noël notamment
sont ils sûrs et bien c'est notre
question cette semaine alors ces jouets
sont testés et évalués avant d'arriver
en magasin pour autant certains ne sont
pas conformes arrive à passer à travers
les mailles du filet regardez ce
reportage réalisé notamment avec les
douanes au port du havre il est signé
elsa monde un gars va
al'approche de noël pour tous les
parents c'est le même casse-tête l'achat
des jouets alors comment faire son choix
entre les milliers de modèles
disponibles
personnellement l'argument premier c'est
le prix forcément
donc je vais à ce que le cadeau puisse
entrer dans le budget défini je regarde
ce que ma fille me donne en principe
principalement c'est gênant dans sa
gamme des envies des enfants pris le
critère sécurité ne vient qu'après car
les parents sont rassurés par la bonne
réputation de cette chaîne de magasins
lorsque les clients viennent dans nos
magasins pour eux cette étape de
conformité elle est faite en amont par
nos équipes produit en tant que
commerçant la première chose que vous
faites quand vous sélectionner un
produit vous regardez s'il est aux
normes donc bien évidemment il ya le
marquage qui sur la boîte mais aussi le
pays de conformité que le fabricant met
à votre disposition
donc vous avez une information sur le
packaging et nous en tant que
professionnel on va chercher
l'information auprès du fabricant pour
certifier l'information qui est sur le
packaging des contrôles effectués aux
différentes étapes de commercialisation
cela commence lorsque les joueurs
arrivent en france au port du havre par
exemple
ces mini moto ne se retrouveront pas
sous vos sapins à noël arrivait de chine
elles n'ont pas réussi les contrôles de
la douane qui ont permis de révéler de
nombreuses non conformité à savoir des
risques de brûlure important dans cette
zone qui est censé être accessible à la
main de visage et également des risques
de pincement entre la fourche et le
cadre de la mini-moto ici ensuite il ya
des non conformités secondaire mais qui
sont également dangereuse par exemple le
carénage qui est trop fragile et qui
peut casser donc présente des risques de
coupure vous avez la béquille par
exemple qui est trop fragile qui
pourrait céder assez facilement pourtant
on note la présence du marquage ce et
eux sensé être un gage de qualité
en réalité celui ci signifie simplement
que le fabricant se porte garant du
respect des normes
cela n'engage que sa parole il réalise
des tests mais n'est pas obligé de faire
appel à un laboratoire indépendant ses
258 mini motos seront renvoyés à leurs
fournisseurs en chine ce qui représente
une perte d'argent pour lui si les
engins avaient été mis sur le marché
c'est l'importateur qui auraient été
responsables et risquer des poursuites
il se trouve que la douane d'un protège
effectivement le consommateur mais la
douane protège également les
importateurs face à ces produits en fait
qu'ils arrivent non conforme et
l'importateur lui les avaient commandées
en toute bonne foi il ne pouvait pas
s'imaginer que son fournisseur
allez lui expédier ses motos non
conforme c'est à dire qu'en fait il doit
être très atteint tout importateur doit
être extrêmement attentifs lorsqu'ils
sont jugés suspects les jouets prennent
la direction d'un laboratoire d'analysés
commun entre les douanes et la
répression des fraudes
les jouets ils passent un sale quart
d'heure ils sont étudiés sous toutes les
coutures
pour vérifier qu'ils respectent bien les
normes européennes qui sont appliquées
dans toute l'union depuis 2011
ici on vérifie que le nez de cette
peluche ne se détache pas voilà pendant
10 secondes en voiture et à 90 du temps
là on mesure la solidité de ce téléphone
premier âge et il y a aussi le
redoutable tests d'inflammabilité la
vitesse de propagation de la femme doit
être fait pour que l'enfant puisse se
débarrasser
et la vitesse
le test est réussi puisque comme vous
l'avez vu la vitesse de propagation et
relativement l'autre inférieur à 3 cm
par seconde
les contrôles sont de plus en plus
poussés notamment sur les métaux lourds
la situation s'améliore mais il faut le
dire que la réglementation aussi se
renforce au cours des années par exemple
depuis 2013 la recherche des métaux
lourds s'étaient étendues à 19 éléments
alors que jusqu'à présent c'était
uniquement sur 8 sur mille jouets
contrôler l'année dernière dans ce
laboratoire 15% ont été déclarées non
conformes
nous accueillons sur ce plateau philippe
juvin bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
européen et ce dossier vous le
connaissez bien vous est notamment
membre de la commission du marché
intérieur et de la protection des
consommateurs alors justement philippe
juvin parlons-en des consommateurs et
notamment des plus jeunes d'entre eux
est ce que globalement les jouets qu'ils
ont en main sont sûres
oui globalement les jouets qu'ils ont en
main censure mais ils sont sûrs parce
qu'on y veille parce qu'il y à des
réglementations qui sont maintenant les
mêmes partout en europe qui fait qu'il
ya plus de pays où les jouets sont sûres
et d'autres pays où les jeunes le sri
lanka ya peu de temps encore mais bien
entendu d'ailleurs une directive c'est à
dire une loi européenne a été votée il y
a maintenant cinq ans qui a été
appliquée dans les droits nationaux
c'est-à-dire transposée dans la loi
française en 2011 est désormais les
français ont la même loi de protection
des enfants à travers les jouets que les
allemands que les italiens et que les
polonais importants ont dit que
l'allemagne n'appliquerait pas
totalement la nouvelle directive sur les
joues et la direction quelques-uns que
sur quelques éléments les pays ne jouent
pas totalement jeu mais globalement on a
un niveau de protection qui est le même
il faut savoir que les jouets qui
viennent en europe
majoritairement de chine entre par un
certain nombre de ports essentiellement
le havre on l'a vu dans le reportage
rotterdam également est typiquement si
le port de rotterdam n'a pas les mêmes
règles que le port du havre est bien
c'est comme si nous avions des trous
dans notre cuirasse donc il était
important d'avoir les mêmes règles la
réglementation existe en même temps on
voit bien qu'il est impossible de tout
contrôler et quand on voit ce qu'on
avait dans ce reportage c'est pas
forcément fait pour rassurer
comment savoir que beaucoup de produits
ne passe pas à travers les mailles du
filet ne se retrouve pas dans dans les
dents les dans les magasins d'abord
quand on est donc à la fois des enfants
quand on est acheteur et quand on fait
la hotte du père noël au moment de noël
il ya quelques questions à se poser
tout d'abord est ce qu'on achète dans un
endroit qui est connue référencés
qui a bonne moralité je veux dire si
vous achetez un jouet à la sauvette
il ne faut pas vous étonner ensuite
d'être face à des jouets qui poseront
problème soit des problèmes de sécurité
est l'exemple typique qui n'a pas été
évoqué là c'est celui de la batterie à
l'intérieur du jouet qu'il chauffe trop
on a connu des jouets mal organisée par
lé lé nounours qui parle qui ont leurs
batteries qui devient très chaude
rapidement parce qu'il ne serait pas
conforme donc un jouet qui n'est pas
conforme il peut être dangereux
un joueur qui n'est pas conforme il peut
être tout simplement très fragile et on
connaît ses jouets qui au bout de
quelques jours sont déjà fatigués ça ça
témoigne que ce sont les jouets qui ne
sont pas conformes à comment on les
repère quand on est le consommateur a
d'abord on essaye de l'htc jouait dans
des endroits référence est connu à ce
que globalement les grandes chaînes
jouent évidemment le jeu elles n'ont pas
intérêt à s'amuser à importer des jouets
qui ne serait pas conforme
et puis on se pose des trois questions
de bon sens quand un jouet très cher
vous ai vendu pas cher du tout c'est que
peut-être peut-être il ya anguille sous
roche
et donc c'est une attitude logique qu'il
faut avoir
donc si on respecte toutes les consignes
que vous nous donnez on peut se fier au
marquage de conformité c'est on peut si
on peut s'y fier parce que c'est une
garantie que le jouet a répondu à un
certain nombre de critères
alors il est vrai que de temps en temps
mais exceptionnellement le marquage ce
est battue en brèche
parce que le marquage chez eux c'est un
engagement moral juridique que prend le
fabricant
et on peut imaginer que certains ne
jouent pas le jeu on l'a vu avec les
fameuses motos chinoises
en plus il faut connaître la
responsabilité c'est celle du fabricant
ou nmx le fabricant est responsable mais
l'importateur lui-même c'est-à-dire la
société française pour simplifier et
aussi rachetés sont jouées en chine est
responsable et donc c'est ça qui est
aussi protège le consommateur sait que
si par malheur il arrivait quelque chose
ou si simplement le joueur était
défectueux eh bien ils n'auraient pas à
écrire à une société au fin fond de la
chine mais ils pourraient s'ils
pourraient s'adresser à la personne
qu'il a apporté en france ailleurs sur
le marquage se font connaître une
anecdote qui montre bien que là où il ya
une vraie guerre commerciale avec la
chaîne c'est que les chinois ont inventé
un label c'est eux
comme par hasard qui signifie china
export et nous sommes en conflit avec
les chinois pour ça ou pas du tout nous
sommes en conflit avec les chinois pour
beaucoup de choses mais c'était cet
exemple montre bien que l'europe ne doit
pas être naïve
quant à ses rapports commerciaux avec
ses partenaires en particulier mais
pourquoi philippe juvin y at il tant de
jouer venus de chine on imagine que
c'est aussi pour des raisons de prix
est-ce que c'est pas possible
aujourd'hui de faire du made in new york
pour ses pour les jouets qui représente
un marché important quand même en europe
d'abord vous avez raison le marché
européen du jouet c'est le premier
marché du monde alors c'est pas rien 27
fois jouets vendus dans le monde sont
vendus en europe ton corps voilà nous
nous jouons beaucoup en france en europe
pardon et en france à paris en plus
alors nous ne fabriquons pas et il s'en
faut de beaucoup tout les joies qui sont
commercialisés en france
mais nous avons une industrie qui les
imaginent c'est à dire qu'un jouet même
s'il est fabriqué en chine parfois aura
été imaginée inventé en europe
ça signifie que c'est une industrie très
importante pour nous on considère que 60
% des jouets vendus chaque année en
particulier au moment de noël sont des
jouets qui ont été inventés ou ré
imaginer dans l'année qui a précédé et
pourquoi ne pas les fabriquer ici parce
que ça coûte trop cher et bien
probablement lorsque nous avons coup
du travail un coût de fabrication qui
est trop élevé et donc l'avenir de
l'europe c'est quoi c'est à la fois
continuer à être les premières en
imagination et en création ce qu'on
appelle le recherche et de développement
et puis si nous pouvions avoir une
industrie qui deviendront plus
compétitive
c'est tout le débat que nous connaissons
par exemple en france pourquoi en france
nous avons une industrie qui n'exporte
plus c'est parce que nous avons une
réglementation qui est assommante et
nous nous mettions nos secteurs de pm
donc il faut sauver l'industrie du jouet
et en particulier entre autres il faut
la sauver
parce que c'est une industrie qui
fonctionne qui a des clients qui est
innovatrice et qui doit être protégée
parce qu'elle est aussi une industrie
qui crée et c'est pour ça qu'au niveau
européen nous devons aussi avoir des
règles communes de protection de la
recherche et de la de la propriété
intellectuelle une tête de la petite
question puisqu'on parle de jouer et
notamment de nouveaux matériaux qui
entrent dans la composition des jouets
notamment les métaux lourds et vous êtes
médecin
ils vivent est ce que ça peut avoir des
conséquences pour la santé qu'est ce que
c'est que les taux alors les métaux
lourds ce sont des produits qui sont
hautement toxiques pour certains pour le
pour le pour le corps humain et les
réglementations aujourd'hui européennes
sont parmi sont les plus protectrices du
monde donc on peut avoir confiance et on
peut avoir confiance parce que même
quand elles existent celles qui existent
ils sont à des taux infiniment bas la
santé merci philippe juvin d'avoir été
notre invité je vais y aller ce livre
que vous avez écrit notre histoire les
100 dates qui ont fait la nation
européenne
et si nous étions tous des enfants de
l'europe je lis la quatrième de couv
alors ce expliquerait peut-être ce
sentiment qui a toujours uni les
différentes nations celui d'appartenir à
un grand tout au delà des frontières de
chacun expliquez-nous pourquoi avoir
fait ce livre est ce que le sentiment
européen
existe encore moi je crois que le drame
de l'europe c'est que les gens ne voient
qu'à travers la voix qu'à travers des
directives et des règlements compliqué
or l'europe c'est une civilisation qui a
des racines qui viennent de la grèce qui
viennent de rome qui viennent de la
chrétienneté qui viennent des lumières
et ses racines elles ne sont pas
françaises allemandes italiennes et
polonaises
elles sont européennes et mes héros
liste - les héros de l'histoire de
france sont aussi les héros des
histoires voisine donc moi je plaide
pour qu'on enseigne une histoire commune
aux peuples européens parce que cette
histoire existe déjà et les voilà votre
première pierre en français donc chez
jean claude lattès
vous allez le faire traduire dans
d'autres langues de ta paire parce que
c'est un livre d'histoire européen qui
sera traduire l'anglais en allemand à
minima
alors là ça peut être donc à une bonne
idée de salon mais touré c'est un livre
sont pas toxiques
merci beaucoup philippe juvin d'avoir
été notre invité c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve en début d'année
prochaine d'ici là très bonne suite de
programmes et merci de votre fidélité
ciao